una vez que entro a mi nueva cuenta
creada en khan academy o una cuenta ya
creada con anterioridad
entramos a nuestro panel como tutores o
como maestros en donde se nos muestra un
listado de todas las clases que hemos
creado del lado derecho superior
encontramos siempre la opción de agregar
una nueva clase si yo hago clic en
agregar una nueva clase primero se me
abre una ventana en donde me da la
opción de colocar el nombre de la clase
en este caso vamos a poner álgebra y al
seleccionar el grupo
3b
si nos dice que ya existe seleccionamos
otro nombre y aquí tenemos la opción de
importar la clase desde google classroom
si no tenemos esa opción damos clic en
siguiente y ahora nos toca seleccionar
el tema qué curso vamos a impartir desde
aquí podemos seleccionar matemáticas por
temas de geometría álgebra cálculo
etcétera o bien matemáticas por grados
si es 3º 2º etcétera para los maestros
de ciencias podemos seleccionar cursos
de biología química física si nos vamos
para abajo en el listado encontramos
otras opciones en este caso vamos a
seleccionar álgebra y hago clic en
siguiente ahora nuestro tercer paso es
agregar a los estudiantes recuerden que
siempre que creamos una nueva cuenta o
en una nueva clase perdón a nuestra
cuenta se crea un código especial para
esa clase este código nosotros podemos
compartirlo con nuestros alumnos para
que puedan unirse
a la clase creada para mí desde mi punto
de vista esta es la opción más práctica
y más efectiva porque podemos aprovechar
el momento de tener a todos nuestros
alumnos reunidos en el salón de clase
para compartir con ellos este código y
pedirles que automáticamente
inmediatamente se unan a la clase
también les recomiendo tener este código
visible en algún punto del salón durante
todo el año para aquellos alumnos que se
incorporen más tarde otra opción para
agregar alumnos es a través de una
invitación por correo electrónico al
seleccionar esta opción se nos abre una
ventana en la parte inferior en donde
nosotros debemos anotar los correos
electrónicos de todos los alumnos que
vamos a invitar para esto les sugiero
que tengan ya a la mano estos correos
electrónicos lo único que deben hacer es
separar cada correo con una coma y un
espacio una vez que estén listos vamos a
hacer clic en esta parte inferior en el
botón que dice invitar estudiantes y
automáticamente nuestros alumnos
recibirán un correo electrónico en donde
se les va a notificar de esta invitación
lo único que deben hacer es abrir el
correo y aceptar la invitación y
automáticamente quedarán sumados a
nuestra clase cuando nosotros abrimos la
clase que creamos siempre tenemos esta
opción de menú en todas las clases que
creamos tenemos tareas actividad lista
configuración recuerden que la opción de
progreso solamente aparece cuando
nosotros elegimos como curso una misión
a completar de otra manera
solamente verán tareas actividad lista y
configuración si yo hago clic en
configuración tenemos aquí
varias opciones para poder modificar
nuestra clase podemos cambiar el nombre
de la clase recuerden siempre guardar
esta información y también podemos
cambiar el tema de nuestra clase si hago
clic en cambiar el tema recuerden que
puedo además de un curso ya elegido
puedo seleccionar otro recuerden guardar
también a su información de no ser así
seleccionan un único curso dan siguiente
y cambian el tema de su clase
por otro lado desde configuración
también pueden eliminar esta clase al
hacer clic en esta opción aparece una
ventana en donde nos preguntan si
estamos seguros que quieres eliminar
esta clase de demo con 'la & lo único
que deben hacer es hacer clic en ok y la
clase será eliminada de su lista gracias